let's go next
to
um
let's go to itai
from copenhagen denmark
hi david it's good to be on it's a
pleasure to have you
yeah um i wanted to ask you um what are
the odds that given the democratic
presidential candidate in 2024 wins the
electoral college and the republican
candidate refuses to concede
that the republican-controlled congress
will overturn the election and make
uh said republican candidate the next
president of the u.s
so that that's that's a really good
question so let me let me restate the
scenario so people understand it
some democratic candidate wins the 2024
presidential election maybe it's biden
maybe it's someone else they win they
get more electoral votes they are
supposed to be the next president
however
republicans let's imagine control both
the house and the senate
could they successfully prevent the
winner from becoming the president of
the united states
my instinct itali is to say no it
wouldn't happen they don't really have
the power they tried to take that power
some of them did in 2020 they don't
really have the power so there's no way
in hell that they prevent the democratic
winner from becoming the president
that's my instinct
but then i think about well hold on a
second
even in 2020
they weren't close but they were close
to making it tough
and so if they were in full control
what would happen and then i start to
get a little bit scared
let's hope the former case is true
i also wanted to ask you um what topic
would you like to be taught in public
school that would make um the american
public more politically aware and
engaged
uh critical thinking and media literacy
ah that's good i um
i would have picked um a course on
political ideologies so people at least
know what the different terms actually
mean yeah
i see that as only really being useful
if everybody already is educated in
critical thinking and media literacy i
see those as previous prior steps to
jumping into political ideology but i
don't disagree with you
i see
um
i also um wanted to suggest that you
should um
cover less the hate mail that you get
um be it chats and from voicemails it's
because we already know that you are
getting it but um
i mean i mean it's it's a given uh i
would suggest it unless it's
constructive criticism to just ignore it
because it's yeah it's not worth your
time so listen i understand that um we
do uh on fridays in the last segment we
do 10 minutes of emails and usually
there's like two that are negative so
it's like 10 minutes
on one show a week and it's only one or
two of those minutes so i i understand
the opinion it's a really small part of
what we do
oh i see um that was me um
how is yeah here in denmark just uh so
your audience knows the covet pandemic
is
um soon over there are still some cases
but uh we don't wear masks or anything
okay yeah there's really no masks in the
in the us either hey real quick can you
very slowly
pronounce copenhagen the way you do in
denmark because i struggle to understand
how you guys pronounce it can you say it
once slowly for me
in danish or english in danish
it's because the er
is a sound that doesn't uh exist in
english okay and say say it one more
time slowly for me
wow so that so that
the g really disappears
um yeah it does it does it's more of a v
sound got it got it
all right very good thank you i
appreciate the call
thank you david and have a nice day you
too there's it's hi from
copenhagen is the way i say it
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to apostrophe.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description